I'm sitting with Peter Girardi and you
are the head of Warner Brothers
animation no creative director of Warner
Brothers animation let's just say that
you work here at Warner Brothers okay
you guys have obviously the Warner
Brothers characters mm-hmm
you also have the DC characters is that
true mm-hmm Batman Superman Wonder Woman
Trinity Green Lantern Green Lantern he's
coming up as a movie yeah and his power
is he has a green ring that can make
things green is that right he can create
anything he could think of with his
power ring with his power ring but it
has to be green
it has to be green this sounds like
whoever invented this one he was trying
to get out early for a Friday and it was
just like he's got a lantern and it's
green I gotta go
a lot of traffic just put that out there
yeah there are a few characters that you
can look at in the DC Universe that some
time was spent with them other
characters less so I'm glad you brought
that up we went through this book the DC
Comics encyclopedia and of course you
guys have a lot of great heroes but we
found some heroes and I'm telling you
these are absolutely real that well they
suck they didn't work out
I'd like to go through them is that okay
sure backlash he's a smooth-talking
ladies man cowboy dandy with the flower
always in his back he's not a late dandy
maybe gives it away a little in the
twilight of his life in the 1920s he
joined with adventurer Biff Bradley and
Hans von hammer the enemy ace to
retrieve two swords altra the multi
alien this is a mess I don't fear this
person one part is chicken foot this is
longer this leg which isn't even a leg I
think that's just gravy that's and then
of course the unifying principle for all
superheroes that are bad women's
underwear I hope this person wasn't just
fired but then murdered and by okay
let's talk camilia with captain boomer
ass so it's a guy with a perm wearing a
miniskirt flight cap a flight cap from I
think TWA that stewardesses hat Oh
Superman is losing control let's get
Captain Boomerang to throw some wood at
him it might come back or not depending
on wind conditions you know he's got his
weaknesses too though you know Superman
has kryptonite hmm and Captain Boomerang
any enclosed space
to throw a boomerang alright gotta ask
you about this guy Space Ranger
do you know Space Ranger no I have never
seen Space Ranger kareem abdul-jabbar
wore this last year hanging around the
green land he hangs out with the Green
Lantern
my guess is Green Lantern doesn't call
him back this is him checking his
answering machine
[Applause]
again no messages you guys have some of
the best animators in the world here we
have the best some of the best sit down
with one of your animators and maybe
help design a Conan superhero that would
be great like a lot of people I
fantasize about maybe myself being a
superhero and this is what you do now
help me let's let's design a Conan
O'Brien or Conan superhero in real life
I have no but I have no ass it's just
not there can you give me a little back
I guess give you a little badonkadonk
yeah I want my belt with thanks thing it
holds my blackberry on how about buckle
with like my marijuana leaf fliers logo
style I see but maybe with flames coming
off there no oh and kind of Thunderbolt
be going through it and a Star of David
behind it I just
oven mitts maybe there's some steam
coming off the middle because I just I
took a focaccia out of the oven Oh a
highlight gloves and the other one great
you know what I would like to be the
first guy that's wearing shoes like
loafers can you do a task I call shoe
those are great you put little cleats on
the bottom how about sauce like an old
man's socks with garters fishnets and
garters and socks yes this is remarkable
thank you so much cool figure out those
hands you bet those are the hands that
created
you
[Applause]
you